so what did your friends and family
think because it's literally one of my i
think my sister that's like one of the
favorite things i've ever done um i mean
my mom sent me the clip i think between
like four and seven
times as if i wasn't there doing it and
then like hadn't seen the first three
um so yeah she was all systems go
sending it out to
friends and family um i think
dan dan was basically dan levy
was basically hospitalized when he found
out that i was going to be on your show
and it really only started talking to me
again
because he was so jealous and
that i got to perform with you but he
was also jealous that i was the first
one
from the show that got to be on your
show oh my gosh well and we love
i mean does your does the whole shit's
creep cast you all just think i'm nuts
because i totally got up there and i was
like i think this should be shit's creek
and it wasn't a diss to anyone else i
just
love y'all's chemistry your vibe the
show is so great
do you all think i'm nuts you probably
think i'm nuts like maryland no no we're
all like we all
experienced that full like flustered uh
we all whispered about you after you
came up and said hi to us it was really
it was
it was a big deal oh man i'm i'm just
such a fan